jet-ski plongée baignade sur fond blanc
une journée typique sur l'île et la
grotte petit morceau de paradis au coeur
de la baie du robert
mais c'est apaisant c'est apaisant n'y a
pas de luis à l'ats que la nature autour
d'un goût vous voyez des poissons voyez
des étoiles de mer tout est naturel mais
au delà du calme apparent des tensions
existent bel et bien sur cette île est
il y a deux semaines des échanges de
coups ont même eu lieu entre des
visiteurs d'un jour et des occupants des
lieux comme josé des grottes qui fait
partie des six familles ayant des
résidences secondaires sur le site
il évoque un achat réalisé par le grand
père de son épouse il y à plus de 100
ans
même si officiellement l'état est le
seul propriétaire des lieux il ya un
acte qui enregistrait pouvez le trouver
c'est m clarac moteur augmente en 1917
il achète à madame ragot cherchait donc
d'estimer quand même être propriétaire
non parce que on nous sommes respectueux
de la loi la loi ne nous a pas reconnus
propriétaire j'aurais préféré qu'elle me
reconnaissent propriétaire ça aurait été
plus simple
j'aurais trouvé ça plus juste l'ensemble
du domaine appartient effectivement à
l'état est désormais géré par l'office
national des forêts chargé de faire
respecter un arrêté de protection de
biotope mais de plus en plus de voix
s'élèvent aujourd'hui pour dénoncer ce
qu'elle estime être des privilèges indus
de bénéficier qu'à une seule catégorie
de la population meilleure répartition
des terres du foncier s'impose
maintenant à nu la colère qui montre on
ne pourra pas là géré par un petit coup
de procès par petits coups comme ça ne
sommes pas ça ne sera pas la solution
donc il faut entendre la colère il faut
entendre les gens qui il faut discuter
avec eux il faut ouvrir le débat et il
faut que des solutions concrètes et
pérennes soient prises est ce que vous
entendez ça oui monsieur ici là une
occupation qui a près de saint-haon près
de cinq ans et brusquement vous voulez
dire que les gens qui sont là ils ont
aucun droit même si les ont des droits
ils ont des droits à habiter la maison
que leurs pairs et que leur grand-père
le
genlis et dialogues de sourds semble
s'instaurer entre d'un côté ceux qui
jouissent de l'usufruit des lieux et
ceux qui estiment que tous les
martiniquais doivent pouvoir en profiter
ce que nous souhaitons c'est que la
politique le nf même que l'état mène
soit la même pour tout le monde et que
les îlets deviennent la propriété
également et que l'accession assez il
est soit possible tous les produits d'un
point de vue réglementaire l'accès aux
idées et pourtant autorisé à tous à
condition que les règles de protection
de l'environnement soient respectés ce
qui est également valable pour les
occupants officiel bénéficiant d'une
concession de 30 ans 7
cette concession elle se fait avec des
droits et des devoirs
c'est à dire que les personnes qui ont
des conséquences et sion là ils peuvent
pas à grandir ils peuvent rien faire
sans l'autorisation de l'office et ils
doivent également respecter les règles
de l'environnement c'est-à-dire par
rapport à l'arrêté de protection des
biotopes moyennant une redevance
annuelle d'à peine plus de 1000 euros
les familles des grottes et 2 jabron
pouvoir continuer à jouir de l'idée la
grotte jusqu'en 2044 et ensuite la
concession les concessions peuvent être
reconduite si les occupants respectent
les termes de la convention actuelle
d'ailleurs les conventions peuvent être
adaptés ou les conventions peuvent être
non reconduite ça ça se discutera dans
les quelques années qui précèdent rendez
vous en
la fin des années 2030 si certains n'ont
pas l'intention d'attendre et ont appelé
les martiniquais à venir manifester sur
place aux tambours demain matin la
préfecture a réagi en limitant à dix le
nombre de personnes autorisées sur le
site ce samedi